you just had to look at a small box
sufferer
to be horrified
[Music]
it was very much a lottery ticket which
most people didn't want to buy
the eradication of smallpox is one of
the most significant events in the 20th
century for me it would be
up there with the moon landing
you had these blisters these lesions all
over your skin
all these pustules they were filled with
virus viruses
and there are many different kinds of
them can be scattered with each particle
of saliva and mucus
when one sneezes or coughs for instance
[Music]
[Music]
india as in the mughal empire understood
the value of very relation
because it saw smallpox as a threat to
military power
but the problem was that it was as risky
as it sounds you're basically trying to
stop a deadly disease by giving somebody
a mild case of the same deadly disease
their relation could lead to
uncontrolled epidemics
people knew that this was something that
their children would catch
and they might survive or they might die
from it and so it was part of the cycle
of life
when inner inoculated the arm of james
phipps a young boy of eight
with the contents of a cowpox bleb from
a dairy maid
it became possible for the first time to
protect human beings artificially
against pathogenic organisms
this really tipped the table in favor of
prevention eradication to people in the
1700s this was totally mind-blowing
jenna's idea was a game changer
so
what happens in 1948 after the second
world war
the horrors of the second world war is
the worldly greys that a new world order
was needed
what a crazy idea would be to say that
you're going to institute
vaccinations for the entire world
[Music]
the 11th world health assembly approved
a resolution in 1958 calling for
worldwide
smallpox eradication so wh galvanized
enthusiasm they standardized the vaccine
obtained the resources that they needed
internationally
they really deserve tremendous credit
for them
[Music]
people running the program were going
from door to door with pictures of a
child with smallpox and asking
people in the community if they knew
anyone who had this disease
[Music]
you're tracking testing isolating it's a
strategy which
many people have said will be the only
way we can keep on top of
covert 19. may 1980
two men affixed their signatures to an
historic document
[Music]
national and local health workers played
an immense role
in the eradication of smartphones
whether it's in africa or an airship
often selflessly because a disease like
smallpox was
as threatening to them as kovac 19 is to
today's health workers
it's interesting that we're often so
eager to
commemorate success in wars but that
much less is done to celebrate success
in the control of
disease the eradication of smallpox is
one of the most
significant events in the 20th century
for me it would be up there with the
moon landing
we've eradicated smallpox and because
we've eradicated smallpox we know that
we can eradicate other human diseases
if we all work together to tackle the
disease to stop it spreading to protect
ourselves
there is no reason why we can't stop
another pandemic lightly stopped
[Music]
smallpox
you